so the men come in are the trade cons
come in and tell the men to just find a
good woman and I think the problem with
this is that good women don't really
exist if we're gonna go off of the basis
that a good woman is a woman that Waits
until she's married and in all of
history that would have been the
definition of a good woman to start now
again out of the five percent and I've
gotten this complaint from a lot of
church guys that they're frustrated
because Church makes the wives worse not
better or they're not submissive uh
women are still very controlling of the
guy so or you know because of social
media the women get bored and leave